[Music]
i'm tim ferriss author entrepreneur
angel investor and now tv host
i've spent my entire adult life asking
questions then scouring the globe to
find the answers
on this show i'll share the secrets of
pioneers who have faced their own fears
we'll dig into the hard times big
mistakes tough decisions and how they
got through it all
the goal isn't to be fearless the goal
is to learn to fear less
welcome to fearless i'm your host tim
ferriss and on this stage we'll be
deconstructing world-class performers of
all different types to uncover the
specific tactics and strategies they've
used to overcome doubt tackle their
hardest decisions and ultimately succeed
on their own terms so let's take a look
at my guess by the numbers
17 minutes four seconds his world
record-setting breath hold if you can
believe that it's true 44 days how long
he survived without food in a plexiglas
box
63 hours 42 minutes and 15 seconds the
amount of time he spent encased in a
block of ice
for nearly 20 years he has risked his
life for your entertainment please
welcome to the stage world-renowned
illusionist and endurance artist david
blaine
[Applause]
[Music]
so david i have wanted to have this
conversation for years now and i'm
excited yeah we're gonna have fun
tonight and i thought one way we could
start is with a video that maybe does
not represent the most fun but i think
is a good video nonetheless awesome this
is as close as i come to doing a magic
trick focusing you're doing good here we
go
work in the next set of cuffs
from behind
there's a little bit of air in you guys
get ready there are some bubbles
go
go
go are in relax relax we got you david
you're all right you're all right
the divers are in the sphere
okay just relax we've got you
so that is a terrifying video
what happened in that particular
situation why did things go sideways
in training when i had worked on that i
i never the record was i believe that
the time was nine minutes and i'd never
gotten up to nine minutes i got to seven
minutes and 47 seconds
dry no oxygen just breath holding
and i figured
if i starve myself i'm in the sphere my
metabolism everything slows down
i would be able to miraculously hold my
breath much longer and it did the
opposite effects when it came time to do
the stunt i had handcuffs on i was
strapped at the bottom and i just
started to convulse they jumped in to
get me and you can't see in the video
and i was like no like i held my finger
up to stop them because i thought i
could keep going but i'm blacking out
and luckily they did jump in because he
had to take these things off to pull my
head above the water yeah seems like one
of the main dangers of of
any type of breath hole training is you
feel fine until you're not right i mean
some of it but when you black out see i
learned that navy seals as part of the
training what they do is
they make the seals comfortable with
blacking out underwater so what they do
is they strap them to 45 pound plates
and make them walk the bottom of a pool
and they walk until they black out
underwater and then they get pulled to
the top and they're brought back and
they're fine but that makes everybody
not afraid of drowning with no fear
because you've already blacked out
underwater we've already experienced
we're scared at ted med where you have a
great presentation it's been a hugely
popular talk but what i remember
personally
was with a small group sitting in the
audience and having you you held your
breath train people so check this out
guys or maybe i'm making this number up
maybe 15 people in the audience you got
up to almost five minutes i got to 3 33
i remember very specifically but there
was there were people in the audience
who got past five
and these were people completely
untrained my breath hold record for me
was around 45 seconds i have lung issues
and i got to three minutes and 33
seconds and there were other people just
kept trucking that was maybe 15 or 20
minutes of exercises yeah 20 minutes
total that was scarier than any of the
stunts that i've ever done talking
at that conference oh talking at the
coffee yeah the stunts are easy but i
was in front of like 500 of my favorite
people you being one of them
and
i had never given a public talk where i
wasn't doing magic so just to stand
there and have to talk in front of
everybody that i respect so much i was
like three days three nights no sleep so
that was its own stunt so i mean it's
all relative right guys i mean he's not
afraid of that but he's afraid to talk
in front of 500 people so whatever your
fears might be kind of puts it in
perspective what was your what was your
childhood like how would you describe
your your childhood early childhood i
grew up in brooklyn with a single mother
and
we didn't have much she worked multiple
jobs but she was so incredible because
she allowed me to
dream imagine yeah there's you see and
also do you see i have leg braces on oh
yeah so i was born i was born with my
feet turned in
and
so i couldn't run fast and i couldn't
swim fast so at the age of five i was on
the ymca swim team and that's where i
started to learn to hold my breath
because in order to keep up or even be
faster than the other kids i learned how
to swim without breathing so all the
other kids had to learn how to do this
and i would just swim straight across
and that's right that's where i started
to develop an ability to hold my breath
wow but so back to my mom yeah so
she was just
the i could ask for nothing more amazing
as she was the best
gift that i could have had as a child
and
she'd walk me through the park all the
time and even if i was late for school
like one time i was walking through the
park and
i was late so and she was walking me
before she had to go to work and i was
like
mom look there's king kong and instead
of her saying no no we're late let's go
she said where you know she engaged
right so we walked all the way over and
it was just a log you know a tree that
that was down
but the idea that she let me imagine and
believe and didn't want to stifle that
that's that's what made her so
incredible how were you introduced to
magic or magic tricks when i was i was
about five years old my mother gave me a
deck of cards and i would carry it
everywhere that i went it just it was
like a treasure to me and i would go to
the library and wait for my mother to
finish work and pick me up and one of
the librarians one day walked me through
a simple book of magic self-working
stuff
and
when my mother came and i did it to her
and she went crazy i became obsessed
with with doing magic and getting her
reaction and then getting her friend's
reaction so i never did it for the other
kids
because they would have been
really difficult brutal yes
so i was lucky i just did it to my tough
crowd
did you want to be
a magician from that point onward or
what did you think you were going to be
when you're little what did your mom
think when i was five i said to my mom
i'm gonna be a magician one day and she
went that's amazing
so i've got to believe so you've stuck
to the script like yeah
yeah stuck to it
how has she
affected how you live your life today i
mean i think part of she was so brave
you know when i was she got sick when i
was a teenager and fought cancer and she
fought without a complaint she was very
tough but the way she approached
suffering and death was was almost like
she was so graceful about it
that i was curious you know
the suffering that she endured and how
she found so much
beauty out of it i think that was like
one of the
sort of
planted the seed
to
you know what is there on this other
side of enduring things that are
and not viewing it as just a bad thing
and were you uh you were with her when
she passed yes she died in my arm
i can't even imagine oh that was a i
remember at that moment i felt like my
body was like one big twig and it was
like
snapped and i became
really afraid to uh
connect like that to anybody else how
did besides the you know putting the
armor on or not wanting to necessarily
connect in that way did anything else
change but i think also at that point
that's when i became fearless because at
that point i felt like i had nothing to
lose
so when i was 19 or 20 or something like
that i was i was at the airport and my
bag was missing and i saw a whole bunch
of identical bags coming out and there
was all these guys dressed in identical
jumpers
and i was like i think you guys have one
of my bags because i have the exact same
bag it was a tuning bag they said go go
ask him knock on the window and it was a
limousine a white limo parked out front
with tinted windows and i knock on the
window and the thing rolls down and mike
tyson's over his fist up he's like you
got a problem
and i was like and i was like holy [ __ ]
no mike you're like my
favorite person and i grew up with that
you know so um he says jump in so
i jump in the limo with him and we drive
to the hotel he's staying at
and in and i'm doing magic to him and
it's it's amazing and
along the way he says to me says you
know i wasn't supposed to be the
heavyweight champ he's like i didn't
have i wasn't tall enough and enough
long arms he's like but i had nothing to
lose and when you have nothing to lose
you have everything to gain and i was
kind of like that was like another like
a great piece of information from mike
tyson
so you i mean these these types of
encounters just blow my mind because if
i look at like your chronology
so at 18 i think it was uh and
i don't know if this was a milestone or
not but you
i believe this is when you jump to
turnstile got in some trouble for that
yeah can you tell people i was doing i
was doing magic in restaurants
and
it started as a waiter where i would do
magic and then i people wanted to come
back and just see me doing magic so i
started walking up and down
park avenue and trying to get different
fancy restaurants to hire not hire me
let me do magic to the people that were
dining and then they would tip me
as i started doing that i started
getting hired by wealthy new yorkers to
do their parties and things like that
one night i was i jumped over a
turnstile and that's when giuliani was
sweeping everybody so i
i got locked up but as i was going there
i kept breaking out of the cuffs for the
cops that they liked i just love that by
the way
they actually did oh did they yeah yeah
yeah it's so good i have to pause
so you're like hey guys these aren't
working
how do they respond to that yeah no no
they they they're all good i don't they
they know that i'm not really a threat
but you know so it's gonna they're just
anyways they know they just have to go
through the motions yeah so i get put in
central booking
and central booking is crazy it's like
everybody's in and out of rikers so it's
like a tough
room and you're being moved from one
cell to another and there's like 40 guys
in there and i'm like oh man i'm going
to get my ass kicked
so they're the four biggest guys are
sitting on the ground playing spades
so i walk up to them and grab the deck
of cards
from them and i'm like let me show you
something like you know they're they're
ready to
kill me
and i start doing magic and then what
happened
was they started to go crazy and these
are the toughest guys in the cell so
then the whole cell is around me you
know 30 guys or 20 some guys all going
crazy and then the guards come in and
everybody was reacting to me doing that
like they were all going crazy again i
was like whoa
so
these people on park avenue these super
powerful people and then in prison
these guys the reactions are so amazing
and so similar i want to show that so
that became the impetus for the first tv
show which was called street magic you
know the guys that do three car money
right right all right this is that game
for you right now not for me bro no no
no no no no money but no money is to
just pretend instead of three cards
hold your fingers like this so hold your
fingers like this look watch
this card right remember diamonds forget
ace just diamonds hold the pile what
card do you have
what what card is that
can i look at it yeah yeah but name it
name it what is it
diamonds just diamonds look show it to
them make sure it's all right bingo all
right show it to them too bingo bango
bingo bango cool man hold it like this
look
lower lower level watch this one same
thing just remember hearts forget ace
just hearts watch this switch ready
see i switched it look i'll do it again
see it switched back just switched twice
so quick you didn't see it get it off my
shoe huh all right all right
yeah switch twice look i'll do it so so
you could see it look here's the move
see how the borders line up don't put it
on the bottom look no i'm teaching you i
know i'm teaching i'm teaching you right
now that's how i do it hold it tight
that'll make it impossible because you
know the move i have diamonds ready
right without looking at it what would
you bet on hearts of diamonds
all right but pretend bet would you bet
hearts here or hearts here or could i
impress you if the heart was on top
diamonds on bottom your heart's on top
because you had to turn your hand over
go ahead turn your hand over
[Applause]
everybody thinks they're so different
but really there's also generalities
among people so you can really kind of
look at a group and you can estimate
which person's going to react a certain
way and you get better and better as it
the more you do it
no it's kind of like what psychics do
sorry like psychics basically when you
walk in they profile you right away and
they've done it so many times that they
can kind of cold read
what you do where you're from what
you're looking for whether you're
skeptical whether you're not so it's
like
you just learn to read people read the
queues yeah what's what are some lines
or approaches that you use when you just
cold approach somebody there was there
was a magician named harvey cohen
that i used to love
he taught me so much and he would
approach people
when he would do magic and he would say
he was very fumbly with the cards
but while he was fumbling cards he was
secretly like loading cards in your
pocket doing all this stuff so he'd kind
of approach with this non-approach it
wasn't like look i'm a magician i'm
going to amaze you it was almost like he
couldn't hold the card so you'd be like
hoping that he was going to succeed
and then then at the end when you
thought everything had gone wrong and
there's two cards in your pocket and one
on you know
so it was like the the the approach that
i always liked to do magic is the
opposite of what a magician would do
because i always imagined if somebody
could really do magic they wouldn't
really have big pattern they would kind
of be fumbling they'd say look at this
thing and then just do something right
so that was always the approach was
simple
simple and understated i think is the
best approach at what point did you go
to acting school you did good actually
yeah i went when i with brian callum
who's amazing i learned so much from him
hasn't he decided to go to acting school
well you know there's a famous quote
that orson welles said but it's from
roberto dem where he says uh a magician
is just an actor playing the part of a
magician so at that time i was i was a
close-up magician there was really no
there was no business in it there was no
way to make a living at it so i figured
i would study acting and take it
seriously and maybe apply it to magic
and see what happens
and it was a really valuable year
because
what you learn in acting school is
living truthfully in a given imaginary
circumstance so it's interesting because
when you apply that to magic it's like
instead of these are just tricks you
kind of like almost believe what you're
seeing on some level not believe it like
ah how'd i do that but you kind of
play into that as opposed to the silly
pattern the silly trick and it i feel
like the magic comes to life that way
you know it makes a performance more
interesting
one of the best things brian taught me
there he was he was an early mentor to
me one of the quotes that his dad gave
to him is always surround yourself with
people that will inspire you or help you
grow and that was just a great piece of
advice from him i took that very
seriously and pursued people that i
looked up to or that i admired and and
tried to learn things from them since i
didn't have really you know a father
figure or anything like that
did you look for
father figures kind of throughout that
adolescent period or was it was it more
surrounding yourself with peers no well
i mean early on i would read about all
the people i looked up to and you know
that was kind of like my college was
finding people that did things that i
was really amazed by and then learning
as much as i could and and then what i
started doing is i started finding all
the books on nobel prize winners and
then in literature specifically and then
i would read what books they recommended
and then i would read the books that
they recommended and on the back of that
book it would be what this book was
influenced by so i started going through
lots of that stuff the original
hyperlinks bibliography yeah yeah
when did you start fasting
and why i've been obsessed with fasting
since i was a kid but i think it started
when i my mother gave me siddhartha to
read the hermann hesse book and i read
it when i was 11 years old and in it he
fast and he stands and he does these
things where he sees the world in a
different way and and and he realizes
that he can control his body and with
his mind so that was the beginning of
the the seed of the curiosity and then
loving the way you feel when he fast
like colors change the blues become
vibrant you notice the sky
you become more emotional
so i took everything away and it was
incredible so the fasting so siddharth
is one of my favorite books
absolutely and i remember have you guys
read that it's a short read it's amazing
and
i remember at least in two instances so
he's trying to
court this
uh noble woman i think she is and he's
also trying to get a job with a merchant
at one point
and they ask him because he's
effectively at least acting the part of
monk at the time they say what can you
give what can you do and he said
i can think
i can wait and i can fast yeah and he
talks about the value of not being
beholden to food he says for instance
if you asked me to work for you right
now and i needed food i'd have to say
yes to whatever you offer me since i can
fast
i can think about it more rationally but
i've done seven and ten day fasts i've
never gone as far as you have but
uh it's incredible when you click over
from
carbohydrate dependent to pulling on
your fat stores i mean cognitively it
everything changes it's very very
interesting it's hard to go like you
can't go back to how it was before in
terms of viewing food and so on yeah
it's totally different looking back over
your stunts
all the magic the endurance feats
which ended up being more dangerous
than you expected or scarier than
expected
probably the 44 days with the water fast
in london in a box because
i think i went into mild organ failure
and i dropped the 33
bmi which was well documented but it was
uh the recovery on that i think to this
day it's it still screwed up my
metabolism and my weight goes up and
down really fast and it did real damage
that's a vitamin deficiency so the
pigment
leaves who has been there 44 days no
food only water
i lost 60 pounds in 44 days
the plexiglass diet not not recommended
not recommended
your dietitian will not have this on the
multiple choice options
what did your
refeeding look like after that well that
was a really interesting part so
after i did the 44 days i was rushed to
the hospital where i stayed for i think
two weeks when they started re-feeding
me i think my phosphate levels jumped
out of control and i almost went into
shock and died and that was
the refeeding syndrome yep we published
a paper in a new england journal
medicine about the refeeding syndrome
which is because most hunger strikers in
the past they do it in their very
anti-government anti
you know it's for a statement whereas i
just did it as a performance piece
and therefore i was willing to give all
my bloods and all my urine to doctors
and let them use it as research so it
actually became
useful in the sense that there was a
real documented study of
the prolonged effects of
fasting 44 days or starvation
technically yeah
were there any any of your performances
on the flip side that you thought were
going to be very difficult or very scary
that were easier than expected for you
for whatever reason
nope
what does magic mean to you because you
you do so much more
than illusion and magic mean you really
have sort of a full stack
performer kit at your disposal but what
does magic mean to you
and for me it's just a beautiful
performance art like it's something
where
and it's also like
you learn a really difficult skill
it defies logic
and then you have an immediate reaction
to it so it's something you can do
almost anywhere anytime and it's also a
constant pursuit
of information but information that
isn't readily available so it's like you
have to dig up history you read about a
guy that had done something from 100
years ago he died took his secrets to
the grave so you spend
years trying to d you know trying to
understand how he did it and it's trial
and error practice repetition and then
finally all of a sudden
you're you know able to do these things
that
you had only read about like one was you
know called the human aquarium which is
about a guy that could convert his body
into an aquarium where he could store
creatures another was
yeah i'm not kidding this is another
yeah another was a magician another one
was put a sturgeon in his mouth and like
regurgitate it well anything yeah
anything that could live in water and
and land but then then you also find
there's another guy that was the human
dragon and he could drink kerosene it
would float on top of a gown of water in
a stomach and then he would
blow fireballs out of his mouth igniting
a huge fire and then just when he
thought that was the end he'd use a
gallon of water that was stored in his
stomach and put out the fire
but of course of course one time he did
it wrong and died so
[Applause]
but and took his secrets to the grave so
you know inadvertently yeah but so i see
the footage i'm like i want to do that
you know so i spent like 20 years trying
to figure it out and i couldn't because
there was no
nobody
nobody had the secrets so i was like oh
man maybe this isn't such a smart idea
[Laughter]
so we uh we're gonna pull up
this video involving an ice pick you can
see how complex and how dangerous to
take an object and put it through your
hand is and especially where david's
doing it there's a whole complex of
arteries there
[Music]
you want me to pull it out yeah gnarly
no
nothing
just a hole
blood
nothing just a hole there's not any of
any blood on this thing you nothing
explain that one dr ruben
[Laughter]
okay
i don't think that deserves applause i
think that deserves like you're out of
your mind condemnation
off the stage but ironically
before i leave i brought
another thing similar that i have an
x-ray of that i'll i'll show you that i
recently learned so i'll show it to you
before i go yeah it's a little crazier
than this one i think the only way that
i can even begin to approach talking
about that is let's assume that it's
totally real like you actually figured
out how to put that through your hand
that's the
the only place i can go with it
what is your self-talk when you're
practicing that
well i mean houdini used to do this
thing where he'd push
pins through his face and then pull them
all out swallow razor blades but not
threaded but
there there are
ways to
to do things that are real that that you
know you would assume it can't be done
because you would assume that you're
going to bleed but there's a way to and
i started with acupuncture needles just
trying to see if you could go straight
through
i had x-rays taken mrs you know the
whole thing so i could know where all
the blood vessels and everything lie
and then i found a sweet spot and just
started you know
slowly figuring out how to go through
the hand
is there any particular trick or stunt
that has
obsessed you for a long time that you
have not yet been able to feel yeah the
craziest one i've been obsessed with
with the idea of sleep deprivation
yeah but could know but when you do
sleep the deprivation like the the
native americans would do it and they
would
you get this really incredible
hallucination
yeah so it's like
any i've done like five and a half days
with no sleep and that for me
hallucinations start to really kick in
at like 55 hours if i'm standing up the
whole time and it's a really rough
environment and it's even though it's
scary it's also like you're having these
dreams and these nightmares but you're
awake but the north koreans used it as a
ultimate form of torture on the
americans when they were hostages and
many of those hostages came back tweaked
for life so it's like there is what is
the breaking point the the risk benefit
right analysis
so i remember at one point it's one of
my favorite parks in new york city
bryant park was that where you were on
top yeah
i was gonna stand on this pillar for a
day and a half with no food no water and
nothing to catch me if i fell
my legs
hopefully i'll survive
i remember reading at one point that
talking about hallucinations the
buildings became like wolf heads yeah
animal heads yeah animals and you look
back they see the shapes of just normal
buildings and you suddenly think wow
that looks like a lion so i was up there
for like 36 hours but i started
hallucinating at like hour 30 but just
light hallucinations so the buildings
that were behind me that were perfectly
flat
i started looking and i was like wow i
didn't know those buildings were lion
heads
so the people down below
yeah but yeah that's light so the people
below that were working on the thing and
the
you know people at abc
suddenly decided that there's no way i
was gonna hit my target so they built
this huge thing of boxes it was enormous
which pissed me off
and i ended up jumping and hitting the
mark but
that was during mild hallucinations
have you ever learned anything from your
hallucinations very curious not trying
to imply that you have to have it yeah
yeah for sure just curious because i i'm
now
in my mind comparing it to say
some descriptions of the psychedelic
experience no
yeah also you have that as well but but
one of the things that i did learn
is out of
anything that i did that was extremely
difficult
when your brain starts to go like when
you start to lose control of your mind
there's nothing is horrific
imaginable
so it's like i never understood
when somebody has mental illness i never
understood how severe that is
but it's like when i go through those
things and it's like all of a sudden the
world becomes scary because
you don't have control anymore
and i learned that like now anybody that
i meet that has any kind of
mental illness in any way
i i i'm extremely compassionate toward
not just compassion but like yeah this
is this is this this is the craziest
thing ever when that starts to set in do
you have you developed any strategies to
cope with it well that's interesting
because basically what happens is your
brain
is trying to trick you
so the brain knows
that you need sleep
so the brain can recover and you can
your immune system everything is built
so what happens is when you're staying
awake even if you have people helping
you your brain is coming at you with
your biggest fears and anything that is
your weakness
your brain is trying to say this is
happening to you and you need to go to
sleep otherwise this is going to get
worse and worse so you start seeing like
blemishes appearing but they're not
there you see your hand changed into
spider webs like everything that would
freak you out so you would decide i
can't do this anymore is going so you
have to do it often enough and have a
very sensitive careful team around you
that are guiding you almost
that
teach you how to override what your
brain is trying to tell you to do
that's pretty good yeah it's pretty wild
also a train skill do you have
any fears what are you afraid of or or
what makes you anxious anything i don't
i'm not i don't well first of all i used
to be horrified of insects i would see
like a cockroach
but i think i learned that from my
mother because she was really afraid of
bugs but then i went to botswana africa
and
i was sleeping in this little tent
with these hippos circling the tent all
night
and
you're there by yourself and you're in
this little tent filled with spiders and
all these bugs and they become like your
good friends you know because you're
like these hippos could chomp you in
half in one second so i mean you're
mentioning something that i think is
really worth underscoring because it
seems to come up a couple times which is
if you're afraid of something you can
try to think your way out of it or you
can just expose yourself
yeah to it and sort of inoculate
yourself with these
these
these small doses so yeah if someone for
instance cato is considered the perfect
stoic
and he cared how people judged him at
one point he was very concerned with how
other people felt about him so he
started wearing odd colored clothing and
so on so that he would get ridiculed he
did it on purpose so that he could
practice
not caring about being embarrassed about
things unless they were truly important
right
and
practicing poverty similar idea right
even i say you take seneca or some of
these other famous stoics and they would
take a certain period of time and eat
the cheapest of food
sleep on a hard floor bare floors
exactly so that they would know you know
is this
is this the condition i so feared is
what they would ask themselves
so i want to pull up some audience
questions
from twitter this is
at t-y-k-o-e
what are somewhat average things that
you can't do despite all attempts
dance
dance
[Applause]
[Laughter]
a karaoke god yeah that's a tough one uh
[Music]
not much i always do
nothing but a hound dog i don't know why
it's like my default i'm like i can't do
karaoke but that's my go-to it's like
wearing the odd clothes so you can be a
stoic we should just go out and karaoke
until we're i'm horrible
be hard watching at least uh yeah uh the
next question is somewhat related to
what we're just talking about what is
your secret reserve of strength when you
feel that your body or mind can't push
through that's that's a really good
question
so what i what i do is uh a lot of it is
based on numbers
so i create and i and i run it across
the board so
it's like if i'm if i'm gonna run a 10k
i make sure that i get not just to the
6.2 but i'll go always further like
maybe to 7 or i'll pick a number that's
important
and then i have these superstitions that
if i don't get to this number something
terrible is going to happen
so by committing to this
this almost superstition
that's that's based on numbers
you can use
you know the halfway mark like okay i'm
going to get to 22 days of a fast but i
know i have 44 days so first i reach the
22 day mark and then i start counting
backwards i said we already did half so
that happens so now i can pretend i'm
starting fresh so i have 22 days to go
so let me get through another 11 days
let me get through and it's just it's
basically just breaking it down
in in little chunks but making sure that
you get to that finish line
didn't you do something or have a very
similar superstition when you're a kid
in school really like your school bus
you have to do certain things uh pull a
leaf off a tree or oh yeah yeah or
something terrible
yeah yeah i would stop and there'd be a
leaf that was just out of reach when you
jump and i just keep jumping and jumping
then i have to put something down until
i got that just little things but it's
weird because when
when i for me it was almost like
training because i'd set a goal that was
very difficult and then i just wouldn't
quit until i got it and part of it was
the superstition of doing this
ridiculous thing that has no meaning but
just not quitting until it's done this
one's from facebook this is patrick
makuka zagambo i like this question i
have 90 days to practice
to perform a close-up magic event
what skills should i focus on to
maximize my results in such a small time
frame i mean the way i do it is not the
way others do it but what i like to do
is i like to commit to something and put
myself in the hot seat because i already
committed to doing something that i'm
not ready for so i know like your thing
when you did you know a week to get
ready to do something so you're all in
because you have no choice so even just
when i do certain
big magic stunts or feats i i announce
them before i do them and then i work
diligently to get there so
i would say
find
a few things
that that you really like
work on them
research them
learn how to do them and they're going
to be very messy
keep working until you start to figure
out how to do it among friends and
family just let me try this try it try
it over and over
and then go out
maybe to a friend's party or wherever
you are and try it over and over and
over and over and after you fail a
couple of you know a few hundred times
you might start to become okay at it you
know yeah and it's it's i find also with
a lot of these questions like this
i think you made a great point people
are looking for more information or some
type of uh particular way of training
but what they really need is just social
accountability and the incentive right
so if you publicly announce it
you will figure out how to make it work
you're committed to it uh i have a buddy
uh aj jacobs he lives in new york he's
writing for esquire really good guy and
he
he couldn't lose weight despite all of
his attempts and he wasn't obese he
described his physique as a python that
swallowed a goat like just kind of like
middle-aged punch like in the little
prince yeah and he wanted and he wanted
to fix it and so and he and he he had
all the diet books he just wasn't doing
it so he he's a jewish guy he wrote a
check i believe it was to the american
nazi party for like a thousand dollars
gave it to either one of his best
friends or his wife and said if i don't
lose like 20 pounds by the end of next
month i want you to mail this in in
which case his name would be on the
record like public records having
donated to this organization lo and
behold he lost the weight so i think the
accountability is such a huge part of it
uh what are you learning right now josh
anderson on facebook what what am i
learning currently so what i'm working
on is i'm trying to figure out how to
put together a stage show because i've
never really
conquered that and
haven't done it in a way that i feel is
right yet so i've been
working just getting up on like little
comedy stages and
and and trying out different things and
and and the idea of being able to do
something in in in a intimate room and
then also
in a bigger room that that's that's
that's my goal so that's that's the
thing i'm working on
diligently and i'm most
consumed with right now and it's a big
learning curve you know you need to do
thousands of shows before you really
figure out what you're doing yeah so
it's hard to get that
time and space necessary but that's
that's my big goal working on your
material
yeah figuring out how to work that yeah
i mean i remember watching a comedian in
the documentary with jerry seinfeld and
also another up-and-comer and i was it
was it was so sobering
and reassuring to watch because you see
seinfeld who's
one of the biggest stars in the world at
that point and then he goes back to work
on new material as a stand-up and you
just see him bomb you see him bomb in
these little venues and he just forgets
his lines and he just sits there on
stage
and he's like a minute
trying to remember his lines it's just
excruciating but it's reassuring in the
sense you're like okay
this guy it's not like he just wakes up
in the morning with a finished one-hour
set no
you just have to put in the time to hone
it and refine it
so when you think of the word or hear
the word successful who's the first
person who comes to mind for you
my mother
she was a schoolteacher and she
came from a very powerful family left
her family moved to brooklyn decided to
do
social work and teach and things like
that and she was really
incredible and really cared about
doing
and helping and giving and so to me
that's that's like the greatest thing
you can
do so she was
in that regard extremely successful
what's success to you
personally
when when you give as much as as you you
can you know i think like
um bill gates is a great example because
he
he's made so much money but he basically
figured out that he knows that he he can
figure out how to give it better than
most institutions can so he directs his
money outward so it's not like i want to
have so much it's like i want to amass
this amount so that i can
give it to the right places i think
that's really important and um
you know for me personally it's like
one of my favorite stories so
around thanksgiving
whenever i can i go to bmc which is the
brook army medical center
and i go into the burn unit there
where all the kids that are burnt from
the war and just
terrible tragedies so every year that i
would go i try to get everybody that i
can and one year there was a kid
named victor who was 21
and
a really handsome kid
that
got blown up in a humvee
and when he was rushed to the hospital
he had basically been burnt exactly on
half of his face and the top of his head
but half of his face was completely
burnt the other half was perfect
and
he wouldn't go out he wouldn't interact
with the other people he would he stayed
in his room he was
he was more angry that he was suddenly
burnt on half his face and the actual
losing the fingers losing the ears all
that stuff
and
i asked the nurse have i done a verse he
said yeah but there's one kid but he
won't see anybody
he's not he won't even talk to the
nurses he won't meet with their nothing
i said bring me to him
she said no no no he won't see anybody i
said just bring me to him
so she asked his mother who was standing
in the room with him all the time
dying inside
and the mother's like sure i mean my
son's not going to talk to him but sure
i walk in and uh he's like stone face he
won't even look at me let me try and i
grab his hand
which people don't touch him like that
like like like nothing's wrong it's like
guys let me show you something and
pulled your hand out and i start doing
magic to him
and all of a sudden because i'm not
treating him like he was disfigured
suddenly
i see him interested then i keep going
and he cracks a little smile and
i see his mother when when that happens
bawling in the corner but holding it so
i'm like fighting my hardest not to cry
anyway i i could completely finish doing
magic to the guy i put my hat on his
head which you should not do because
it's open wounds and i leave
the hospital content that now i had done
magic to everybody including the guy
that didn't want to see me
and then
i decide to come back the next morning
the day after thanksgiving and the
mother comes out and she's bawling and
she she says to me
when she sees me she's like right when
you left
my son let the nurses put him in a
wheelchair and he went out with the
other guys and he started his physical
therapy
so it was like just that little bit of
like being
treating him like there was nothing way
and so
i came back the next year and uh he had
all this so he looked really good he had
all this reconstructive surgery
and uh and it was in texas and i took
him out for dinner and then to a strip
club we had we had the time of our lives
it was amazing
wow all right
i it's hard to follow that up with just
about anything but uh
what is what is your
if you have one your end goal with magic
what drop what keeps driving you i mean
i think the ultimate goal is just i
always wanted to just bring magic to the
people you know just bring magic in a
good way
or in a new way or in a different way or
you know so that's the end goal
yeah maybe we should try something in
here yeah we could try something in here
you guys want to try something live
all right
so
how should we how should we begin can i
take
the uh the x-ray
so one of the
new things that i've been working on
might be hard to see but
i'll let you hold this up
so this is an x-ray
can you all make it out somewhat can you
all see what that is see yeah there's a
sword
that i recently learned how to push all
the way inside
like a sword swallower basically and i
learned it to work on one new trick
so if i could yeah good
so here's my little now you guys are
seeing this when it's brand new
so and this is much bigger than the one
in the picture the one in the picture is
actually
pretty thin
and the esophagus is is very very thin
so i'm gonna try to push this down
inside
and lots of people assume when sword
swallowers do what they do that it's a
trick but it's really not i recently
learned that in studying this
i don't know if i'm going to succeed but
we'll try
you got to come closer though
[Applause]
to make sure it's real okay
uh
yeah that's real
i'm not going to have him try it yet i'm
going to gift him a week to learn it
let me give this
it might have some food and stuff
should we try this one other thing
i'll let i'll let tim help
so there's something else i've been
working on which is a strength thing
um
just because you're the closest you want
to help with this
do you mind you'll have to jump up on
stage i'll take i'll give you here good
so
one of the things i've been obsessed
with is is just feats of strength
but tim can you mix the deck
shuffle it up
not very good let him shuffle too
i'm like my crew but you agree that
they're they're all shuffled there's no
order nothing like that yes
it's a tin
i'm going to give you a uh like a
quarter of the deck okay
just
yeah like yeah tear it in half exactly
oh god here we go
that's
all together so it's one neat grip and
make it neat all together oh my god try
it
i'm gonna mess this up no but put them
like uh like this flat and then yeah and
then rip it so it's one unit
otherwise you're ripping one card at a
time that's the only way i can do it
so it's difficult it's difficult so i'm
gonna teach you the technique right now
so the idea is this
so
see i pinch here
and then
and it's almost like
pretty simple
see
was very cool
but okay you know what
what which half do you want
uh this one okay so take that and now do
this for me
cut pick up a bunch of cards put them on
bottom
yep and put them on the bottom good and
do it again pick up a bunch put them on
bottom great
now every time you do that the top and
the bottom card and the middle cards
everything is going to change understood
so every time you do it
the order changes yep
this time
i want you to do it behind your back so
behind your back i want you to cut the
deck complete the cut
and then keep them behind your back
good and they're slippery don't let them
spill and take either the top piece or
the bottom piece and put it in your hide
it in your pocket either the top or the
bottom it's up to you
and we don't need the rest of the big
pile good so here's the idea can i give
you these yes
so just to show you that they are
shuffled you you did mix everything up
correct yes yes i'm gonna have you just
choose one from inside
okay actually we'll do a few so here you
just just reach in and pull yeah pull
one or two one is fine
now let me just say something
most people
would go for the obvious card like the
ace of spades
or even the king
you didn't do that you shifted you went
to a card that was not obvious
what card was it the night
the seven of spades
so when you chose you had the choice and
you shifted around and pulled one
but behind your back you didn't know
what you chose
you just pulled the card
without looking and hit it in your
pocket
correct
so you have half of a card in your
pocket and there's another half of a
card in your hand
you want me to take it out sure
let everybody see
put them together see if they fit
david blaine everybody
if you had a huge billboard you could
put anything on it something short
meaning get a message out
to the world what would you put on it
i mean it's the last thing that my
mother said to me is god is love
what does that mean to you well to me it
means like love is the ultimate god so
like loving everything and everybody and
not being filled with hate or animosity
or fear and trying to find love to me
that's like that's the ultimate in life
david blaine you're amazing guys give it
up for david blaine
all right thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you